welcome to this video playing front
knocked our with black yeah I had to set
the sky before and we we played them we
played a real oh pense I want to do
something else and doing a little bit of
experimentation hoping for and not that
critical line going for the modern
defensive now okay this is one of the
active main lines that white has assets
at his disposal okay that's early early
reform and not sure how good this is but
at least that make sure that the Kings
side is not opened up that quickly now
okay now this will be interesting
definitely I have a fairly solid
structure here and I have some ideas
that me oops not that one want to try
for night see for ya here I was thinking
maybe I can go d5 really try to make the
e pawn move so that the King side is
really frozen and he's quite far away
from putting something on c5 is this
weakness on c5 is of course now imminent
but it's no he cannot put something
there quickly okay let's push some at
some points here and possibly get in
Bishop a 6 ok at least I was quick here
yeah do I need to Castle probably
probably I need to have some at some
point I will need this rook the only
thing that worries me is some sacrifice
on h5 but maybe just night f warrant and
smash them if I take on d3 he will take
with the pawn and that sucks really not
not good getting open getting the C file
open so have to be cautious them I'm
ahead on the clock that's not bad but
how do I proceed yeah maybe a queen d7
rugby aid then trying to do something
drastic at night a 43-yard night c4 it's
taking its time I don't know maybe you
really night f4 and take on age 5
don't know kind of a long thing here I
know is this connected don't tell me
that in this interesting position now
that's always bad you never know what to
do with those games it sometimes happens
and I always ask myself sure to upload
this anyway and is this really worth
uploading but ok it was an interesting
opening play at least hard to tell about
this position maybe really night air for
this is at least what I mean flighty for
hd2 disconnection unfortunately it's
really really an interesting position
but yeah i will upload it anyway maybe
this opening can be interesting to
people this is this is a quite
interesting setup here this is this
black setup is quite quite a good for
initiating a complicated fight the g4
I'm not sure about the early G for a bit
not sure in a sense that i really don't
know if this is something that like is
glad to get or not i mean at least this
is flexible and i have some attacking
chances myself this is of course ya can
argue about that move but now i make
some progress and here after castles it
is connected i was thinking this but now
that i think of it maybe some counter
play here with possibly e5 can can do
the trick that's really interesting i
have pieces near the king and here as
well so I mean maybe this
it's a total chaos I don't know what it
is I mean this is definitely a dangerous
position for black yeah but he
disconnected unfortunately robbing us of
a of a good fighting game yeah well
anyway thanks for watching